All passengers must go through airport security.
Here are some tips to help you get through like a pro.
Give yourself plenty of time to go through security...
...and have your boarding pass ready to present to a screening officer.
Families or passengers with special needs who need a little more time...
...can take advantage of the dedicated Family Special Needs line.
To avoid alarming, remove metal objects...
...like keys and spare change from your pockets.
Put them in your coat or carry-on bag before passing through.
Cell phones, tablets and other electronics can stay in your carry-on.
If you have a laptop, take it out of the case and put it in a bin.
Your clear, plastic resealable bag of liquids, aerosols and gels,...
...your coat and your purse also go in the bin.
Avoid wearing clothes with metal snaps and buttons,...
...belts with metal buckles,...
...steel-toed shoes or shoes with metal arches or shanks.
Following these tips can save you time during screening.
You may be required to undergo additional screening.
If so, you have a choice between a full body scanner or a physical search.
For more information, visit the CATSA website at www.catsa.gc.ca.